what role does Iran play in this war and
this connection to Hamas it can you
speak to the connection between Hamas
and Iran that's important to understand
especially as this most recent attack
unfolds sure so the correlation I mean
there's reports that Iran is behind the
attack Hamas has has thanked Iran for
their support and um and it's been very
well known that Iran supports the
destruction of the state of Israel and I
won't say Iran as a country I'll talk
about Iran in the leadership there's
actually a beautiful thing I saw on the
internet where at one of the soccer
games in Iran they were trying to you
know rally support for the Hamas uh
Terror attacks and a lot of people in
the crowds were chanting you know Fu to
the regime because I think the Iranian
people the Persian people generally are
peaceloving people who don't want to see
this focus on destruction and
Annihilation but uh you saw this in 2015
2016 when the Iranian government had
resources the the region was less safe
and since you know now uh there's been
more resources allowed to go to the
Iranian regime uh by lack of enforcement
of sanctions and as a result Iran is
funding Hezbollah Hamas um they were
funding the houthis now there's a little
bit of a Daton between Saudi and Iran
which has led to that going down which
only further proves that Iran was behind
the houthis which is what the Saudis had
been saying for years and Iran was
denying so there's a very strong um
relationship between the two and we
always knew that the way that Iran
fights Wars or fights conflicts is never
directly it's usually through its
proxies and in this case a Hamas has
been a proxy for Iran who wanted to
obviously see the destruction of Israel
but also does not want to see the
Israelis and the Saudis uh come together
for a peace
agreement